Hello and welcome to the second exercise in this series,
and we're going to be doing a state tree for this one.
Now, for this, we're going to need to change the level.
You'll see that we have a directory down here called state tree.
If you open that up, you should see that we have a level in there.
Okay, that's going to take you to a separate level that looks like this,
very similar to the previous one, however, it says state tree level here.
And if you hit play, nothing should really happen.
So we're back to a starting point.
Now, if you want to set up state trees,
there are actually a couple of plugins that we're going to need for it.
Now, if you came up to edit and on the plugins,
if you just type in state and tree,
you're going to see that there are a few different plugins,
but the two that we're worried about in this case,
is the gameplay state tree and state tree.
So gameplay state tree just gives us some extra
functionality around using it directly with AI.
Okay, so to start with, we're going to create our state tree.
So if you right-hand click, come up to artificial intelligence,
you can see at the bottom here, we have an option for state tree.
Now, when I select that, we're going to have a couple of other different options come up to us.
In this case, we are going to use the state tree AI component, I think.
And we're going to call this STC underscore NPC.
I'm going to double click on this.
This will bring us into the standard state tree.
Now, there's one thing we need to do in order to make sure that this is all set up correctly.
And for that, I need to add the state tree component.
Now, I'm jumping into our NPC state tree here.
Now, you can add a state tree to any actor and have it run.
However, we are using the AI version at this point.
And so I'm going to delete the one that's on here.
If there's not one there, don't worry about it.
This needs to be added to the AI controller.
So if I select the top one here, and I'm searching for AI in the details panel,
I can drag down, I can see my AI controller class is here.
AI controller, state tree.
I'm going to push the browse to it.
Double click to open that up.
And this is where I will want my state tree to be added.
So I'm going to push add, and I'm going to search for state tree.
And again, I'm using state tree AI.
And what I need to do is in the dropdown, I need to select the state tree we've just created.
So that would be STC underscore NPC.
And we've automatically got star logic automatically.
So that should work.
But it is important that you run from the AI controller in this case,
in order to get it to work correctly.
Now let's jump into our open state tree again.
And you can see that we have a couple of different settings.
Now I'm going to start off with the asset details element on the left hand side here,
because that's going to give us access to the setup variables that we need.
Now, the first thing we want to do is make sure that the context is correct.
And by default, we have the context as a pawn and the AI controller as AI controller.
That's pretty good in this state.
We should be fine with that.
So if we look at the overview of what we're looking at here,
again, on the left hand side, we've got the asset details.
And this is quite useful.
It's going to allow us to get access to the different elements
that we're going to be drawing data from.
So the context would be the pawn itself and the AI controller.
And we're going to have some parameters that are going to be changeable,
and the evaluators and global tasks.
We'll touch on how these work a little bit later on.
In the center here, we have the actual states.
And this is going to define the logic of how we move between these different states.
And that will come more apparent again as we start to build this up.
On the right hand side, we have the details panel.
And this, again, is contextual.
So it will change dependent on what you have selected at any one time.
And across the top, we have our toolbar.
So what we're going to do here is
we are going to start off by creating a new task.
Now, we've already created a number of tasks.
So I don't want to make you redo what we've done in the last one.
However, we're going to start off by creating a task using the state tree task blueprint base.
OK, and we're going to call this
STT underscore move to location.
Now, again, we have our blank task and we have our dropdown of overridable functions.
Now, we're going to work with enter state.
Now, this is going to be triggered as we enter into this state.
There are a couple of other functions
like state completed, functionality run on completed.
And we have a tick.
But enter state and maybe exit state are going to be the ones that we most often use.
So I want to move the character to a location.
So to do that, I'm going to drag off of here and I'm going to type in
move to a location or actor.
Here we go.
And that looks good.
Now, I am going to add in some finished tasks.
So I'll drag off a file and do finish task, much like the tasks that we were using in baby tree.
It's going to want to know where it's finished, or at least
for certain tasks, we're going to need to know where it's finished.
So on failed, I'm unticking the succeeded and on success, I am going to tick succeeded.
Now, we need to have input pins to this move to location or actor.
And there's two that are important, and that is the location and the controller.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to right-hand click and promote both of them to variables.
So I right-hand click here.
We have a controller and we have a location.
Now, it is very important what category these variables are in.
I'm going to set both of them to be instance editable,
so that we know that we want to change this.
And for the AI controller, I'm going to change the category to context.
And what's good about this is it is going to automatically figure out
that this wants to be connected to the context of our AI controller.
I'll demonstrate that in a minute.
Now, for the goal location, I'm going to change the category to input.
And this is a recognized category.
There's actually one other category as well here.
I'll just demonstrate by duplicating it.
And that is output.
And the input and output variables are very important when it comes to tasks in the state tree.
So if I was to compile and save this,
then jump back to our state tree and add a task to this condition.
You don't need to follow along.
I'm going to be removing it in a minute.
But when I add in that task that we've just created,
move to location, STT, move to location,
you can see that we have a few different options here.
Now, the first thing is our controller is automatically connected to the context AI controller.
So you can see it has a list of the variables.
Now the goal location, if I was to compile, is going to error because the input,
anything that's marked as an input, needs to be bound to something.
So we'll go through it.
But because we placed that into the input category, that's showing up here.
And because we put the goal location zero into the output, it's showing up here.
Now I'm going to delete this task because we don't need it there.
We're going to build stuff out a little bit.
And I'm going to jump back in and I'm going to remove this output task.
I just wanted to drum home the point that the categories in these tasks are very important
because the state machine is going to use it differently
dependent on what category you place those variables into.
Now, before we leave, there's one last thing that I want to do.
Now, you can see on the move to location or actor, there is a tick box for lock AI logic.
Now I want to untick that.
Now, this is because we are going to want to possibly stop this task during the process.
However, if you lock AI logic, it's going to prevent us from doing that.
So just by unticking it should mean that we can control how this goes by using the state tree.
OK, so I am happy with this task.
Now, what I'm going to do is jump back into our behavior tree
and it's probably worth following along at this point.
I'm going to add an extra state in.
So you see, I've got one state that comes off of the root here.
I'm going to call this idle, and this is an entire state for the character.
It's going to be idle, and it automatically has a link back to the root.
We'll play around with these as we're going.
But I'm going to have another state that's beneath idle,
add another child state in, and this is going to be called wander about.
So we are mimicking what we were previously doing here,
but we're setting it up using a state tree.
So we have wander about.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to add in some tasks.
So with that selected under the tasks, I'm going to push the plus here.
And the first one that I want is change color.
So you should see we have change color as an option.
And because the context is already set up, the actor is already set down.
Now we're going to set the linear color.
We'll do that in a bit. Let's get all the tasks in first.
So the next one we're going to add in is change speed.
And next it is find random location.
And next up we have move to.
So we've got st move to location.
There is another location in there, but we're going to be using the one that we've just created.
Now you'll see that if I did compile, we get a bunch of failures,
because we have a whole load of inputs which we have not bound to variables.
And the things that we need to bind are all the ones here.
So we need to bind the color, the speed, the location, and the goal location here as well.
So the first one we have is color.
Now we want to set this color on this actual task.
So what we're going to do is we're going to use a parameter here.
Rather than an overall parameter that we have here that's set for the entire
tree, we're just going to have a parameter which is set for this specific task.
So we can see that this is of type linear color.
So I'm going to add, and I'm going to select a linear color.
Go, and again, we're kicking off, so I'm going to set this to yellow.
And so we've got a bright yellow for our linear color.
And I'll probably click down, select rename.
I'm going to call this color.
And now on the input of the change color, I can do a drop down,
and you'll see that I have an options of how to connect these up.
Now what I want to do is I want to connect this to the parameters from this state.
So root, idle, one for about, color.
So you can now see that is connected to that parameter.
Now I need one more parameter, and this is going to be a float.
I'm going to rename as well to change this to speed.
And we wonder about, I'm going to set this to 200.
So we have the speed here, I'm under the speed in.
Again, I am going to take, I'm going to link this to our parameter.
So we've got parameters under root idle.
We're looking for speed that gives us our input.
Now we've got a location out here.
We've got no binding.
That's because we don't need to bind that to anything at this point.
But we do have an input vector for goal location.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to bind that to the find random location task.
So I'm going to do a drop down and you can see that it is detected
the root idle, where about, wonder about.
And I can select the output property of the previous task.
Okay.
And so that gives us our setup.
Now we should be able to hit compile and save.
And when I push play, we should now see that all the characters
are just slowly wandering around the scenes here.
And then they're turning yellow in the process.
If I was to simulate that as well, if we were to jump back into the behavior tree,
we can see here that I've just pulled up the debugger.
And if you don't have that automatically, you can just click on the debugger here.
And that's going to show you all of the different characters.
And you'll be able to see what any of them are doing at any one time.
So it's great for looking at lots and lots of different characters.
It doesn't give us the same detail of a specific character without selecting one of them.
You can see here I expand this hilt.
I didn't seem to be away to.
There you go.
So we can pick the specific tree and we can see what it's doing here.
So that's the debugger for you.
And again, they're just wandering around.
So that's a logical point for us to stop.
We have the character set up and moving about.
Now we just need to expand and add some extra states.
We'll be doing that in the next videos.